♪ ♪
>> Sean: WELCOME BACK TO
"HANNITY," TONIGHT YOU ARE
HEARING THE VERY PAINFUL
STORIES, ANGEL FAMILIES, MOMS
AND DADS, THAT HAVE LOST THEIR
LOVED ONES TO ILLEGAL IMMIGRANT
CRIME.
YOU KNOW, THE MANUFACTURED
CRISIS, LIKE THE SINGH FAMILY
PAIR THEY LOST A 33-YEAR-OLD
POLICE OFFICER, BROTHER, RONIL
SINGH, JUST A DAY AFTER
CHRISTMAS, KILLED IN A TRAFFIC
STOP IN NORTHERN CALIFORNIA
AFTER THE SUSPECT, GUSTAVO PEREZ
ARRIAGA, HAD A LONG CRIMINAL
RECORD AND SUSPECTED GANG TIES,
BUT CALIFORNIA SANCTUARY POLICY
PROTECTED HIM FROM BEING HANDED
OVER TO I.C.E., WHICH WOULD HAVE
MEANT HE WOULD HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED.
OFFICER SINGH WAS AN IMMIGRANT,
A LEGAL IMMIGRANT, WHO CAME FROM
FIJI, CAME TO THIS COUNTRY AS
ALL IMMIGRANTS DO, LEGALLY,
BECAUSE THEY WANT A BETTER LIFE,
THE HOPE, THEIR DREAMS, FOR
THEMSELVES, THEIR FAMILIES,
THEIR KIDS.
TO RAISE A FAMILY.
BUT IT WAS CUT SHORT BY A
CRIMINAL ALIEN WHO NEVER SHOULD
HAVE BEEN HERE IN THE FIRST
PLACE.
AND WHO WAS IN THE CRIMINAL
JUSTICE SYSTEM AND SHOULD HAVE
BEEN LONG DEPARTED.
JOINING US NOW TO TALK ABOUT HIS
LIFE IS HIS BROTHER, REGGIE
SINGH IS WITH US.
I KNOW THIS IS STILL FRESH I'M A
THIS IS RAW FOR YOU.
YOU MET WITH THE PRESIDENT
YESTERDAY.
YOU WERE IN TEXAS, WHERE WE
WERE.
WHAT DID THE PRESIDENT SAY?
>> YES.
THE PRESIDENT JUST WANTED TO
KNOW HOW THE FAMILY WAS DOING,
IF THERE IS ANYTHING HE COULD DO
TO HELP OUT.
WE HAD A GOOD CONVERSATION ABOUT
RONIL.
HE ASKED SOME QUESTIONS.
>> Sean: YOUR FAMILY CAME HERE
LEGALLY, IT TAKES A LONG TIME,
RIGHT?
YOU'VE GOT TO GO THROUGH, IT
TAKES TIME TO GET HERE?
>> YES, WE CAME HERE IN 2003, IT
TAKES ABOUT TEN YEARS, I WOULD
SAY, TO GET -- GO THROUGH THE
WHOLE PROCESS, THE MEDICAL
BACKGROUND CHECK, CRIMINAL
BACKGROUND, IF EVERYTHING IS
FINE, THEN THE PROCESS IS
PROCEEDED TO THE NEXT STEP.
YES, IT IS A PROCESS, YOU COME
HERE, IN RONIL'S CASE, WE WERE A
GREEN CARD HOLDER FOR FIVE
YEARS, THEN ASKED TO GET HIS
CITIZENSHIP IN ORDER TO BECOME A
LAW ENFORCEMENT AGENT.
>> Sean: HE ALWAYS WANTED TO
BE IN LAW ENFORCEMENT?
THAT WAS HIS DREAM?
HE WANTED TO PROTECT AND SERVE,
HE ALWAYS WANTED TO DO THAT?
>> YES.
HE ALWAYS WANTED TO BE A
LAW ENFORCEMENT, A COP, IN
CALIFORNIA.
THAT IS ONE OF THE REASONS WE
CAME HERE, SO HE COULD BECOME A
COP.
>> Sean: LET ME DEAL DIRECTLY
WITH THE FACT, YOU HEARD THE
COMMENTS OF THEN GOVERNOR JERRY
BROWN, DISMISSING THE FACT THAT
THE SANCTUARY STATUS STATUS OF
CALIFORNIA HAD ANYTHING TO DO
WITH THIS, BUT THE REALITY IS,
THE INDIVIDUAL THAT KILLED YOUR
BROTHER WAS ALREADY IN THE
JUSTICE SYSTEM.
BECAUSE OF THE SANCTUARY LAWS,
THAT PREVENTS OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA FROM INFORMING
I.C.E., HAVING OVER ON THE
RELEASE DATE OF THEIR PRISON
SENTENCE, HANDING OVER TO
I.C.E., THAT INDIVIDUAL,
ENFORCEMENT OF FEDERAL LAW.
DOES THAT MAKE IT EVEN MORE
BITTER FOR YOU?
IT IS HARD TO LOSE YOUR BROTHER,
BUT WHEN YOU FIND OUT WE HAD
HIM, HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED, AND HE WAS PROTECTED
BY A STATE LAW?
>> SO, YEAH, WE WAKE UP WITH
ANGER THAT THIS COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTABLE.
I WASN'T AWARE OF WHAT CENTURY
STATE, THE RULES AND REGULATIONS
MEANT, BUT I WAS EXPLAIN HOW
THEY WORKED.
HE COULD HAVE BEEN
PREVENTABLE, WE WAKE UP WITH
ANGER THAT HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN
DEPORTED IN THE FIRST PLACE, BUT
HE WASN'T DUE TO THE SANCTUARY
LAW WE HAVE IN CALIFORNIA.
>> Sean: I KNOW THIS IS FRESH,
LIKE THE CORCORANS, THIS IS NEW,
THIS IS HARD, PAINFUL.
YOU ARE IN OUR THOUGHTS AND
PRAYERS, I'M SO SORRY.
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOUR BROTHER,
EVERYTHING I'VE HEARD,
INTERVIEWED THE SHERIFF, THE
POLICE CHIEF OUT THERE.
THEY LOVE YOUR BROTHER.
HE WAS A GREAT COP.
THEY ARE JUST DEVASTATED
THEMSELVES, SO YOU ARE IN OUR